President Trump took his attacks on four
Democratic lawmakers to a raucous
campaign rally in North Carolina last
night his supporters chanted sent her
back echoing the president's racist
tweet that the for women of color should
go back to the countries where they came
from
Paula Reid is at the White House Paula
what were you looking for last night and
what did you learn well Tony this rally
in a state that the president narrowly
won in 2016 was a chance for the
president to test out how this
controversial approach is resonating
with his supporters and it appeared
there with him all the way the
president's supporters in North Carolina
turned his racist tweet into a rallying
cry after an extended attack on
representative Lujan Omar she looks down
with contempt on the hardworking
Americans saying that ignorance is
pervasive in many parts of this country
[Music]
omar responded to the president's
attacks and the crowds chants in a
series of tweets last night she quoted
poet Maya Angelou saying you may kill me
with your hatefulness but still like air
I'll rise anti-semitic screams in an
exclusive interview with Gayle King this
week Omar addressed past comments that
some have criticized as anti-semitic
would you like people to would you like
to make it clear then you were not
anti-semitic Oh certainly not yes would
you like to make that clear yes I mean
and that nothing I said at least to me
was meant for that purpose the president
kept up his attacks on the so called
squad Talib Presley Cortes somebody said
that's not her name I don't have time to
go with three different name we'll call
it Cortes the president is highlighting
the for liberal freshman lawmakers in an
effort to make them the faces of the
Democratic Party ahead of 2020 the
comments are helping to fuel the rise of
a dangerous militant heart left Trump
supporters we spoke to before the rally
agree with the president's approach I
like it because it seems to work see all
these people out here I mean he's got a
lot of following everything is so
freakin touchy with all of them they
have no sense of humor they have no
common sense I'm sorry just a bag of
idiots those supporters also said they
believed that if Democrats keep focusing
on this feud that could help propel the
president to victory in 2020 Gale Paula
thank you that was very very upsetting
to watch last night thank you